[Musique]
une jolie maison de bois comme il en
existe beaucoup à la campagne mais
celle-ci particulière c'est ici que
joseph staline a passé une seule nuit
lors d'une de ses rares visites au front
en 1943 autrefois une bibliothèque la
maison héberge depuis quatre ans le tout
premier musée entièrement dédié au
dictateur on y célèbre un héros de
guerre qui a vaincu l'allemagne nazie
mais pas un mot sur la grande terreur la
famine aucune référence au goulag et aux
millions de citoyens exécutés pendant
ses 30 ans de règne sur l' empire
soviétique
nous
pratiquons site on le lui a pardonné
dilue milla sidorova une résidente dont
les grands-parents ont pourtant souffert
le martyr dans les camps de travaux
forcés et shiwen est
multi m'en dit elle c'est grâce à lui et
à l'armée rouge que nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui
cette réhabilitation de l'héritage de
joseph staline vu de l'extérieur peut
paraître complètement absurde mais en
russie elles progressent depuis des
années
big n
é li na chn bat kova est une des membres
fondatrices de la célèbre organisation
mémorial aux avis sur pied en 1989 par
des dissidents du régime soviétique pour
justement faire la lumière sur les
atrocités du régime stalinien
le nombre des victimes
de terreur de staline
c'est plus de 20 millions
avec ses bureaux aux quatre coins du
monde mémorial a mis trente ans à bâtir
sa base de données à mettre un nom et un
visage sur plus de trois millions et
demi de victimes des photos des lettres
des uniformes c'est aussi la plus grande
collection au monde d'objets du goulag
les ong est devenu au fil des ans un
emblème de la mémoire et piliers de la
société civile russe
dont les recherches s'étendent ou
violations des droits de l'homme et aux
prisonniers politiques d'aujourd'hui
considéré comme un agent étranger depuis
2015 par le kremlin comme tant d'autres
voix indépendante c'est cette même
organisation
tout ce qu'elle représente que le
gouvernement veut désormais liquidées
pour de bon toute menace ait cet espace
réservé civ
mes collègues
toute menace
sans l'aide de mémorial alexander
korobov qu'il n'aurait jamais vraiment
su ce qui est arrivé à son grand-père un
pilote exécuté en secret en 1938 nous
l'avons joint à montréal d'où il a pu
travailler à distance avec mémorial pour
récupérer ses effets personnels des
archives du kgb et tuer les difficultés
mais je ne faisais
comme tant d'autres il a du mal à
expliquer l'acharnement des autorités
russes
aujourd'hui cet indésirable
l'église des victimes
les héros de terreur soviétiques
sont aussi
aujourd'hui les hérauts du rhône aux
autorités
[Musique]
et ça n'a rien de subtil dans le village
de nelly d'ovo à 300 km de moscou
un autre buste de staline fait
d'apparaître dans le décor il est
flambant neuf et gracieuseté d'une école
paramilitaires alexandre corps d'yves en
est très fiers chez les scouts
du stade
staline dit-il aujourd'hui c'est poutine
ancien soldat d'élite alexandre enseigne
aux jeunes qui songe à joindre l'armée
et si staline inspire le respect et la
stabilité un sentiment qui se reflète
aussi dans les sondages nationaux un
rush sur deux comme daniel pense même
que le dictateur sanguinaire mérite un
monument officielle
pour que l'humanité dit il n'oublie
jamais ce qu'il a fait pour nous
c'est mehdi sliti dans les schistes à la
machine de propagande actuelle est
beaucoup plus forte
que la machine de propagande
de brejnev ou de staline ce talent chez
audi seat est le contrôle aujourd'hui
c'est une pâte tout répressif mais c'est
le contrôle discursif
c'est falsifié l'histoire pour mieux
contrôler l'avenir
et ferme immémoriale s'inscrit selon lui
dans cette même optique
sim est mort et voit être fermé
c'est le symbôle de retour au temps
soviétique